[Music]
you are hosting the film Independent
Spirit Awards that right yeah yeah I
all right kind I know it's your day what
you're doing okay
yeah I know what you're trying to get
going here but I'm not gonna make out
with an eagle so not gonna do what I
used to make out with an eagle that's
not gonna happen so why is my I don't I
didn't asked you to make out with an
eagle okay I asked about they film
Independent Spirit Awards yeah I'm
playing a coy I get it but look it's not
gonna happen and even if I was down to
do that if I was down to make I was an
eagle it's not like there's even an
eagle here to make out with so
[Applause]
all right so okay fine there's one here
but even though there's one here I don't
know what that Eagles into I'm not gonna
give you a guarantee that that eagle
even wants to make out with me so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we just got a nice to look into your
technique yeah yeah you get your hand a
grab on to the mandible and hold up I do
what evils like so yeah so I'm hosting
the Independent Spirit Awards and I
think it's gonna be great to be so coy
you just you just clearly met that ego
made out and then we're just able to
detach immediately well you know I'm it
was casual I I'm sure that the eagle
isn't cares
[Laughter]
did you people really go off for it
all the costume the 52 year old guy a
costume is sad there could be a hot girl
in there now there's not the friend of
the girl next to the Eagle no it's the
guy you play go to earlier in the sketch
right in step
[Applause]